good day everyone this is Jack Van Horn
from the USC Mark and Mary Stevens
neural imaging and informatics institute
the home of the bd2k training
coordinating Center and I'd like to
welcome you all to the big data to
knowledge guide to the fundamentals of
data science webinar series we are very
fortunate to have dr. daniel marcus from
washington university in st. louis today
who will be discussing imaging
informatics dr. marcus is a PhD in
neuroscience from washington university
which he received in 2001 where he
remains as an associate professor of
radiology and he directs the
neuroimaging informatics and analysis
Nyack center as well as the human
connectome coordinating facility his
expertise lies in the area of neuro
informatics including the development of
data management systems ontology x' and
visualization tools he's been a longtime
advocate for the open data sharing
effort which he practices through the
human connectome project through other
projects such as Oasis and another one
called X not central his lab leads the
development of the open source X not
imaging informatics platform and we are
very excited to have him here today I
want to invite all of our listeners to
please submit any questions that you
have for dr. Marcus during his
presentation via the GoToWebinar
question submission system and we will
sift through those and answer or get
answers for you on the most salient ones
at the end of the hour without further
ado please allow me to turn it over to
dr. Marcus for his presentation on
imaging informatics thank you so much
Dan thank you jack for the introduction
and welcome everyone who's joined today
and appreciate those who have been able
to come so here's kind of how I thought
we would do this today I'd start by
talking about why imaging is important
and what kinds of imaging are in place
for the kinds of informatics I'll be
discussing and then I'll give kind of I
can insert a didactic kind of background
on imaging informatics infrastructure as
used in the clinic
and then talk about some of the imaging
informatics infrastructure we've put in
place for the research enterprise and
how those two kinds of informatics
interplay with one another and then I'll
talk a bit about some of them from
imaging informatics tools and systems
that we've built to do data sharing and
a little bit about how informatics can
support translational research and then
finally if I have time and that might be
a bit of a stretch I'll talk a bit about
how you can actually make a living doing
imaging informatics and it's something
I've been doing for almost two decades
now and really enjoy and I think a lot
of other folks would find a lot of value
as well okay so why Imaging is important
to begin with and why we might want to
consider building imaging informatics
tools to support it so there's of course
lots of different kinds of imaging that
cover a very very broad spectrum of many
orders of magnitude scale and then have
very different kinds of preparations and
apparatus to acquire the images what
we're gonna be talking about today is
primarily imaging at the millimetre and
submillimetre scale and includes the
many of the common medical imaging
modalities which of course doesn't say
that the other kinds of imaging aren't
important but there's a lot of reasons
why the medical imaging modalities are
of particular interest one of course is
that they're non-invasive and
non-destructive so that they can be done
both healthy humans as well as humans
who are being imaged for diagnostic
purposes and because it can be used in
healthy people it means we can use it in
for research and in healthy research
participants also this kind of imaging
can be done in humans at a timescale
that they can tolerate so typically on
in less than an hour you can acquire a
lot of very interesting imaging these
modalities also allow us to look inside
the organism
that is we can see organs another tissue
below the surface so we can actually see
what's going on internally and we can
see not just the structure of the tissue
but we can often image various aspects
of the function including things like
metabolism or in the brain the bold
signal which allows us to understand how
the brain might be functioning we can
also apply these methods across species
and in particular we can work with with
mice and other rodents to develop the
methods that then can translate into
humans and these same instruments can be
used in the clinic but also been in
research so some of the commonly used
imaging methods include radiography so
of course if you go in and get an x-ray
computed tomography which gives us
something along the lines of a
three-dimensional radiograph magnetic
resonance imaging which includes
anatomic images but various kinds of
functional images as well including fMRI
diffusion perfusion and spectroscopy and
then there's nuclear medicine as
modalities like pet and SPECT that allow
us to see again various kinds of
functional things going on inside the
body there's other kinds of clinical
imaging of course things like pathology
and those tend to have different
informatics requirements and of course
they're very important but a little out
of scope for today's talk and then
there's a lot of non clinical kinds of
imaging like MHz and Oct which again are
very important and may eventually become
clinical modalities but currently are
largely not and therefore a lot of the
informatics infrastructure is quite
different and of course there's lots of
other kinds of imaging at other scales
that again require other kinds of
informatics capabilities ok so let's
talk a little bit about the kinds of
informatics that is in place in the
clinic to enable
images to be collected and accessed by
clinicians and this is kind of a nice
figure showing the overall kinds of
workflows used in the clinic a lot of it
starts with the wrists the radiology
information system which is used to
schedule the patients and to identify
what exams are going to get once the
patient has been scheduled then an exam
can be requested at the modality other
in other words called the scanner and
once the images are obtained at the
modality then those images are
transferred to some sort of data system
using the DICOM protocol we'll talk
quite a bit about that I come here and
the coming up slides in within the
clinical environment the images are
typically sent to a PACs and they're
sent over the DICOM Network protocol the
PACs is the thing that actually stores
the images is like the big image
database when a clinician is ready to
view the images they're transferred to a
viewing workstation over the DICOM
Network protocol and it's at the
workstation where the radiologist does
his interpretation and the results of
that interpretation or CIN typically
back to the PACs
and the wrists systems alright so we
need to talk about the DICOM standard
this is the digital imaging and
communication and medicine although
everybody just calls it DICOM and this
is the global standard produced by the
organization called NEMA
and you know it's a standard because it
took about 20 years to develop and
covers about over 6,000 pages of
specifications it's so complicated that
vendors are required to produce a
conformance statement describing how
they actually comply with this
complicated protocol and you can read
through those conformance statements and
really get an understanding of what
portions of the overall DICOM
standard that a particular device
implements one of the nice things about
DICOM is that it really is a standard
and that it's been universally adopted
by virtually all manufacturers and for
all modalities used in the clinic
interestingly the standard includes a
definition and specification of both the
data format so how the images are stored
as well as the network protocol for
communicating those images between
systems it includes both the acquired
images as well as various kinds of
derived resources so something for
example like a structured report or a
tractography map it can all be stored in
DICOM objects it's a standard that is
ongoing and development to support new
modalities new communication protocols
new data structures it tends to be a
slow and laborious process for new
capabilities to be added to DICOM and
that can be often to the frustration of
those of us on the research side who
need things to move a little faster but
is you know someone necessary for
clinical communications so for the file
format it includes a number of different
components both the pixel data itself as
well as a substantial amount of metadata
about how the images are acquired a
dykon does have kind of its own
terminology that's useful to get used to
refers to the person who's put in the
scanner as a patient of course but the
thing the images that are acquired the
overall set of images for a particular
patient is called a study and the
individual acquisitions are called a
series so those of us on the research
side often call these things on the
patient we might say as a subject or a
participant study we might call a
session or just a scan and then the
series sometimes we call those
just the image or we'll call them will
call sometimes those that scan so we
there's on the research side there's a
lot of kind of mixed and overloaded use
of these terms but they're pretty
strictly is within the daikon side
there's a whole lot of metadata included
so this image here actually shows a tool
developed in my lab called daikon
browser that allows you to open up a
daikon image and inspect all the
metadata and you can look through this
and find really helpful things about
like what date the image was acquired
lots of the particular settings at the
scanner so for an MRI study you would
have things like repetition time and
flip angles and all those kinds of
things that are very detailed low-level
information about how the image was
acquired and that could be quite helpful
for doing downstream processing it's
also important to note that there is a
lot of thi potentially embedded patient
identifying information embedded within
this metadata so for example there is
the patient name in this case we've
already anonymized it and just call them
sample patient but often the data coming
off of the scanner will actually have
the patient name included and to make
things more complicated it's the patient
identifying information is often
included in fields that are as obvious
as patient name but there's more subtle
fields included that can be quite
difficult to identify whether bhi is
included or not and to use the data and
the research environment a lot of effort
has to go into identifying all of that
lurking thi and to complicate matters
more depending on the modality the thi
can actually be embedded in the pixels
themselves
you often find for some modalities
ultrasound as an example where there's
actually the patient name burned into
the image itself and you have to use
tools that actually can go in and edit
the pixels to remove that identifying
information so here's just a blown-up
view of daikon browser
the DICOM networking so this is how when
you have the DICOM file it's moved
around with across various information
systems the there's a number of kind of
unique terms that are used within the
DICOM standard to describe how the
images are moved and how queries are
made the actual movement is done over
tcp/ip using very specific DICOM
protocols that have different names one
a c-store which is actually kind of the
most obvious of the of the ways of
moving files which just says take this
data from a scanner and store it into
some sort of storage device so for
example that pax which as we mentioned
before is the imaging database but then
there's think communications like a C
fine which is to submit a request that a
tool is interested in cases that meet a
particular set of criteria so that might
be an accession number of are a study
date and then the system and the PACs
for example would send a response back
to whatever tool is asking for images of
that meet those criteria so that's the
see find response when the actual tool
is interested in getting the images
after it's Tennessee fine it submits a
what's called a C move request to get
the images to tell the PAC's to send the
images again using the C store protocol
over to the viewer so some one of a kind
of circuitous way of getting the images
instead of just saying you know pull the
image from the pax to the viewer you're
instead saying hey will you push those
images to me so it's a little bit
complicated and takes a little getting
used to this is kind of feels when
you're used to doing web-based kinds of
communication this can feel like a very
weird and sort of tedious way of
communicating but those in the DICOM
community have gotten pretty used to it
nonetheless they've been responsive to
those of us who've been asking for a
more modern networking protocols and
have implemented a thing called DICOM
web which provides restful webster
services for getting these same kinds of
communications is a relatively new part
of the DICOM standard and so it's not
really broadly adopted to date but
hopefully we will be coming in the in
the coming years there's a lot of really
handy DICOM tools that are out there
that those of us who practice imaging
informatics use on a daily basis these
are some of my favorites it's certainly
by no means a comprehensive list we use
DCM forshay this top pax in my lab quite
frequently for a lot of our DICOM
infrastructure and capabilities it's a
nice open source java tool DCM TK
provides very similar kinds of
functionality but using c and then
there's tools like Orthanc and clear
canvas which are really kind of turnkey
PAC systems that are open source and
freely available we use both of those
frequently in the lab clear canvas in
particulars a nice windows-based pax
includes both the server side as well as
a viewer
one of the big challenges in handling
DICOM for research is making sure that
they are properly anonymized and and to
be able to inspect the images we often
use a tool called the clinical trial
processor i'm just developed by our SNA
and is a web-based application to do a
lot of different kinds of DICOM
manipulation and transferring of those
images and routing of those images
between systems the screenshot I showed
before is daikon browser tool built in
my lab which is just a nice handy
desktop application to be able to
quickly review metadata tags to manually
edit them and transfer the images to a
calm storage system for viewing DICOM
images there's a lot of useful tools out
there of cyrix is very widely used the
osirix brand name is for a includes a
commercial product but there's an
open-source version of it called Horus
it's a Mac specific application
but very widely used by the in the Mac
community three slicer provides a lot of
DICOM functionality that can be fed into
a very sophisticated set of analytic
tools and then ohef is producing a
web-based DICOM viewer that has a lot of
capabilities in the advantage of being
entirely web-based you don't have to
install anything on your desktop all
right so that covered a lot of the kinds
of data flows and standards and
networking that are used in the clinic
and those of us who mostly do research
it's very important to be aware of those
because that is the level at which we
need to interface with those systems in
order to get our images or to submit
information back into clinical workflows
and translational context so I'm going
to switch now to imaging informatics
tools that we use really explicitly in
research that have DICOM capabilities
and know how to talk to the clinical
infrastructure but are really more
focused on research types of operations
and if we think about really one of the
differences between clinical
capabilities and research capabilities
they are somewhat different so in the
clinic everything is really about the
patient so a doctor needs to see a
particular patient their current exam
and prior exams and they need to be able
to annotate that patient and communicate
diagnosis to other physicians on the
research side yeah it's important the
individual subject but we're also really
Caroline about group level operations so
things that are done at the project
level and include analyses that are not
just of a single patient but large
groups the clinic is also burdened by
FDA regulations which of course very
necessary to protect patients but are
quite restrictive
and the kinds of things that you can do
with the systems and particularly can't
just code new functionality on it
whenever you want
versus on the research side we need more
agility because we're really trying to
be at the bleeding edge of things and so
we need to be able to easily adapt and
incorporate new functionality Clinic
obviously needs access to all the
identifying patient information whereas
on the research side we explicitly don't
want identifying patient information and
those can often be kind of in conflict
with one another for supporting
interactive workflows on the clinical
side it's important obviously to be able
to link with the more broad medical
record on the research side we're
interested in linking with potentially
very large amounts of non imaging
research data so things like behavioral
assessments or case report forms or
genomics the clinic is often more of a
qualitative type of practice where a
radiologist is providing their
assessment of images by observation on
the research side we tend to use a lot
more automated and semi-automated
quantitative analytics and those are
often quite computationally demanding
and the clinic doctors share the data
with one another are the images with one
another in a somewhat open way right
like so if you're in a hospital if the
assumption is any of the doctors in the
hospital are privileged to be able to
access those images so security is
typically done at the level of
restricting who has within a hospital
has access to the system and making sure
that people outside the hospital done
verses on the research side we're often
sharing more selectively with our
collaborators and then eventually with
the community but as we know that data
sharing follows sort of a progression of
a broader and broader access as data
goes through you know the research
process and publication so considering
these sort of differences we can think
of a workflow
the research side that looks something
like this where we have the data coming
from different systems including the
scanner but also potentially other kinds
of measurements genomics case report
forms and the like and other sorts of
data systems and then the data kind of
goes through a controlled research
process where you have individual
researchers who are working with the
data they work then with their
collaborators you also want access to
the data and eventually if everything
goes well
the investigators share their data with
broader community but this needs to be a
pretty controlled process in order to be
able to kind of secure access to the
data and have the right controls over it
as it makes its way through the research
process so we've developed in my lab a
system called X net which provides this
sort of controlled process for working
with research data so this is what X
name looks like from a web interface
this is a particular X net instance that
supports the human connectome project
but X net is an open-source tool that
anybody can download and install and run
as their own informatics platform it
provides a broad suite of features for
archiving data managing it running
analytic routines visualizing images and
doing markup on images and then sharing
that data with collaborators and the
community it is open-source has an open
restful programming interface you can
integrate external tools with it and
it's pretty widely used around the world
originally because I'm a neuroscientist
we supported primarily neuroimaging but
over the years we've really made strides
to make it a very useful tool for really
all imaging endeavors we think of it as
a platform because it's built to be very
flexible for lots of different use cases
including clinical translational
research large institutional
repositories multicenter studies and
open access data sharing I'll go over a
few examples of those different kinds of
use cases as we proceed here so this is
the x net architecture in some detail
for those who like kind of you know
technical view of things importantly it
does have a full DICOM suite of services
so it does know how to communicate with
DICOM workflows from the clinical side
so you can push images directly from
modalities you can query out to the
packs and you can submit data from X nap
back into taxes and that's really useful
on the clinical side of things and
integrating with with scanners
themselves but most of the interfacing
with X ad is through it's restful api so
lots of other external applications
visualization tools and things like that
can communicate with that snap through
using kind of more modern web
communication i'm gonna be talking you
know more a lot about neck snap because
it's the system I know best but it's
important to know that there's actually
quite a few different informatics
systems to support imaging research
here's some of them coins
Lloris and flywheel are primarily used
within the neuroimaging community - is
is pretty broadly used and within the 3d
slicer community MRI DB is an MRI
focused database MBIA is developed by
the National Cancer Institute and is the
system that underlies the cancer imaging
archive so there's a lot of these tools
that are out there and they have
overlapping but distinct feature sets so
if you're thinking about deploying a
system like this it's really useful to
kind of review them try them out and see
what's the best fit for your particular
project at this point there's you know
there's still a lot of labs that have
chosen to kind of build their own and
kind of glue together various components
largely because there's legacy
infrastructure already in place at a at
a center
but you know a lot of these tools are
getting the point where they're pretty
turnkey they're very powerful very
feature-rich and they're open sourced so
you can add to them so I would suggest
you know considering not building your
own but using one of the tools that's
already available and to consider
engaging with that the open source
development community around that tool
so back to some of the things that we're
doing in X Net
as I mentioned there's full DICOM
integration but there's a lot of other
stuff going on and I'll kind of go
through some of those in some detail
here in a minute the way we organize
data with an X net overlaps or it looks
kind of like the the organization of
daikon but is not completely the same
so we organize data within a project any
data that's added to the system has to
be within a project and that's the level
at which we do all the user access
control and a lot of the kinds of
operations that are done are configured
at that project level within a project
you have one or more subjects these are
the people who are going in to get
experimental data and each subject can
come in for one or more visits so you
might imagine that they come in for
something like a baseline visit and then
a three-month or 12 month follow-up in
within a visit you can have different
kinds of experiments so maybe they come
in for a baseline and they get an MRI
and a pet exam as well as some kind of
clinical workup
each of those kinds of things would be
considered an experiment and then within
imaging experiments you can have one or
more scans so this would be in an MRI
for example you might get a t1-weighted
MP range but you can have multiple scans
you might have a dozen different
individual scans acquired within a
single imaging session and that data
organization is reflected in the
webpages the accident' provides so
there's a project level page that gives
you a lot of information and group level
details about everything that's
happening in that individual project if
you are an owner on that project you
have
various kind of administrative features
on the page that allow you to control
who else has access and what kinds of
operations are configured for that
particular project if you drill in on an
individual subject then you can see the
details of what experimental
experimental data has been acquired for
that subject so this subject for example
has come in for an MRI visit they came
in for a separate MRI visit and within
each of those visits various kinds of
additional data have been included in
the system so there's been quality
control reviews and a dykon review
validation for each of those visits you
can drill into a particular mr session
and then you can see the real low-level
details of exactly what was acquired
within that within that session and you
can expand each individual scan to get
the very low-level details most of which
are extracted from the DICOM when the
images are imported into the system so
there's a number of ways to get data
into X Net
the most frequent one is just using that
daikon capabilities that are already
built under the scanner so from the
scanner console you can just hit submit
and send it to a accident' receiver
that's been configured at that scanner
so this is really useful for archiving
from your local scanners that are on
your network DICOM itself is not a it's
typically implemented a secure protocol
so typically you don't send DICOM from
remote scanners to over DICOM protocol
into X not X that benda as the data come
in it imports the data figures out what
project it's associated with based on
metadata tags in the daikon and then
puts the data into the correct project
it does have an automation scheme that
I'll go in to shortly for removing pH I
and typically replacing it with research
identifier if you are in a situation
where images are being acquired remotely
there's a couple of different options
for how to get it into X net one is to
set up these little relay devices so
these are little Intel nook boxes and
you can actually install kind of a
lightweight version of X net on one of
these boxes and then hook that up to the
scanner
Smit to DICOM using the daikon protocol
into the device and then it submits over
HTTP using x nets restful api to archive
the data in a remote vaccinate system so
you have going into the device DICOM and
then coming out of the device is secure
HTTP to remove to move it over to the
remote system and that's really good if
you're going to have a lot of data
acquired at a particular site for less
frequent sites that are maybe just
collecting a patient or two a week they
can come to the web site and just do a
manual upload using tools that are
included directly on X 10 in all cases
the same anonymization profiles are
executed on the images and importantly
it's done before the images are
transferred from the study site so the
remote system never sees that
identifying information and identifying
information never leaves the local
network acciden also supports doing
query retrieved from the packs see if
the hospital wants to work for the
hospital IT to allow connecting to the
packs you can submit queries to it using
things like patient name or accession
number and find patients of interests
that then get pulled into dedicated
projects on your excellent system
so this is really useful if you have
patients enrolled in a prospective study
that are getting standard of care
imaging that's going through the regular
patient workflows but you have them
enrolled on us on the study have IRB
approval to add those images to your
research database
so the DICOM anonymization that's built
a language that's built into X net looks
like this it's actually looks a little
complicated but it's pretty
straightforward for each of the DICOM
metadata tags which are typically
identified by these by these coded
numbers you can do different kinds of
operations on them so in this case the
operation is to replace whatever's in
that tag 1010 with the values subject 3
4 6 here indicates to remove this entire
tag from the file itself
the birthdate in this case would be just
the tag would be gone here you were
doing some more complicated logic where
it's saying if I find in this tag the
value CCIR
3 T then replace it with this value and
there's quite a bit of different
complicated logic that can be done in
order to achieve the kind of an
optimization that are necessary to
handle potentially very complicated
situations accident' does have a full
user role and permission system so that
you can really add a very fine grain
level control who has access to what
data in the system so you can for
example build a user role call MRI
reviewer and assign that a person that
role on a project and then they would be
able to review and see MRI scans but
wouldn't be able to see any other
imaging modalities that might be part of
that project sitting a very fine-grained
on exactly what kind of data they have
access to and that about privileges they
have with that data accident' also
embeds case report forms or data entry
forms so that you can collect data other
than the imaging so for example if
you're doing a neuroimaging study and
are using the Wechsler IQ scale you
could have a form to capture the
the measurements from that assessment
into accident there are already many
hundreds of forms that have been built
into accident and many people have
shared those with the community it's
also pretty straightforward to add your
own if you have a custom form that you
need to implement X analysis supports a
number of quality control procedures and
this is really critical in the research
workflows because it's so easy to
accidentally acquire the wrong
acquisitions or for the settings of the
scanner to be slightly off of your
expected acquisition protocol so one of
the forms of QC that we have is to
actually review the DICOM fields as the
DICOM is being imported we call this
protocol validation so using a little
specification file you can tell exactly
the system exactly what you're expecting
within the metadata in this case we've
set all the expected values for all of
these fields most of them pass except
for the facing coding rotation was
slightly out of the expected range so
when a session is is uploaded into the
system that fails the validation an
email sent to the research team so that
you can very quickly go and review the
images and potentially even rescan the
subject rather still on site a system
also supports doing more manual review
of the images to look for things like
artifacts or poor head positioning
they're the exact QC procedure that you
use can be configured in the system so
that it captures really your very
specific kind of review process and then
you can do more automated review of
actually running routines to check the
images for various characteristics so in
this case we're looking for motion
artifacts in an fMRI scan and you can
see for this particular subject over
time that they have a number of events
where they're moving quite a bit so this
chart would indicate a subject who was
really moving a lot in the scanner
may need to be given instructions to
hold still and rescan I'd mentioned the
next that has a RESTful API and it's
really a very powerful way to expand
access capabilities in particular by
sharing data between from X at into
various kinds of applications so in this
case we've written a plugin for 3d
slicer that can be opened up and you can
type in your credentials and what X that
you want to talk to you and then it work
through this dialog to select cases that
you're interested in then those open up
inside a slicer and you can do various
manipulations drop regions of interest
and the like and submit those results
back into X nap or they'll be stored
alongside the original images so we have
that for 3d slicer we have it for osirix
and for many other applications a nice
thing that a lot of sites are doing now
because they are sharing data between
different organizations and have lots of
kind of complex workflows is to be able
to do synchronization between two X NAT
systems so that we have a plugin that
allows you to define what systems to
send what other x nets to send
particular exams to and to the plug-in
takes care of a lot of that
communication and handling and you can
build a fairly complex rules in for how
and when that sharing and
synchronization that's done we're
starting to expand on this concept of
there being lots of extant systems out
there and that users might want to be
able to access data across them using
concepts from data Federation so for
example we worked with the dimension
platform UK which is building a
distributed federated network across all
their imaging centers so they have what
is it about 6 or a different imaging
Center
spread across the UK that are all
imaging dementia cohorts and they all
have excellent system set up to manage
the data for their particular cohort and
then from a central hub users can come
in and issue queries that are
distributed across all the different
nodes to find particular data that meet
their interests and criteria they can
submit request to the pis at each of the
different sites and then get an
aggregated data set delivered to them
that they can then work with so this is
kind of a bit of a hybrid Federation in
that the queries out to the data systems
are federated but in the end an
individual data set is produced and
pushed to a central hub where the user
can work from it the logic of that is
that the central hub can be associated
with a large image processing cluster in
which they can the user can then as
cloak the data sitting close to that
cluster so that they can do by
throughput image processing we're
imagining setting up this kind of
Federation not just within a closed
network like the GP UK but globally
across all x net systems or at least all
accent systems that want to participate
in a data Federation the idea would be
not the data within those systems would
just automatically be accessible to all
users but that if an investigator wants
to opt in to sharing their data that
summary information about their dataset
would be published on to the Federation
users would be able to issue queries
across that the metadata not the actual
data but metadata so for example they
could look for across this Federation
for neuroimaging studies of Parkinson
Parkinson's disease that include PET
imaging and MRI let's say and then
result sets would come back that would
allow the user to see datasets of
potential entry
to submit requests to the pis of those
datasets and once given axle they would
then be able to directly access the
actual images the intention of the
Federation is to enable anonymized views
of the data to make it very
straightforward and turnkey to make that
data accessible to the community in ways
that are dump reached the privacy of the
research subjects there's a lot that has
to go into making a Federation like this
work the technical technical side I
think actually is more straightforward
than the the more you know research
philosophy sorts of issues that come up
and and the logistics of how to share
potentially sensitive data but we are
proceeding with with implementing a lot
of the technology having a lot of
conversations with the community about
how data sharing and if this kind of
Federation can be done so one of the
things that accent supports is analytic
infrastructure so that you can run
automated processing routines we use a
technology called docker so I'm probably
most people on the call by now are
somewhat familiar with docker but the
idea is that dr. provides little
containers like little virtual machines
on which you can embed your all of the
libraries executables and other
resources that are needed to execute
complex computational routines and those
can be all packaged up on one of these
containers and then you can share that
container with people they're very
affordable we like the idea of using
containers as ways to embed scientific
routines that can be then be dropped
into a platform like X net and tied to
data and workflows to automate many of
the complex computational routines that
are used in research so this is what the
x net interface looks like for
working with containers there's a user
interface that makes it pretty
straightforward to configure and
identify docker containers of interest
under the hood is a JSON specification
for exactly what all the fine details of
how that container would embed within
accident
but basically it comes down to it
specifies what's the docker image of
interest that can be pulled from
something like docker hub or some other
of the sharing of it the docker
containers and then after that there's a
configuration step to describe what that
container is doing so what kind of
operations are embedded on it and then
there's a configuration step and this is
really the kind of a key to getting it
to work with x net where you tell it
what the images within X then or what
the files or resources within X net that
need to feed into the container and then
after the container runs what did it
produce what kind of files are coming
out of it that can be stored back to X
net so you might say that this
particular container needs the DICOM
images for a particular type of scan and
what it's going to produce in this
example we have it producing nifty files
so it's going to run a nifty kadai come
- nifty converter and store those nifty
files back alongside the DICOM and then
that's really good after that it's X net
really handles the logistics of
executing that container from particular
data sets so from a user interface
perspective for a particular session a
user could come in and once that
container is configured they would see
the command for it sitting right there
on the webpage they could click that and
then it would go and run for an
individual scan level as shown here or
there's a blown-up view of it and guess
that was hard to see or they could do it
at the overall session level so to run
across all of the scans this is sort of
a manual
configuration of this container it can
also be set up to be triggered
automatically for different vents so for
example you might want to run the DICOM
to Nifty conversion automatically when
the session is archived and that's just
a matter of using X Nats automation
system - to configure those kinds of
automated executions there's a lot of
different kinds of things you could
build into these kinds of containers we
just mentioned a data format conversion
so for example going from daikons and FD
but you can do all kinds of other kinds
of computations you might compute an
image histogram or motion mr. Graham's
you could transform an image to for
example register to an Atlas or you
could do group level operations for
building an Atlas one of the common
workflows of
a lot of people were working with is to
do deep learning exercises you could do
take a tensor flow application and
integrate that as container there's
really no end to the kinds of analytic
routines that can be embedded in these
containers and linked into X network
flows obviously it's nice because it
supports you know automation and being
able to easily share these kinds of
analytic routines with your
collaborators one of the things that's
particularly just to me is to really be
able to promote reproducible research
and because imaging workflows to have
tended to be complicated and vary a lot
with different versions of underlying
software knowing how to reproduce
someone's image processing results can
be difficult and I think being able to
share containers won't will really make
that a lot easier because the
complexities of exact libraries and
versions of software tend to go away so
that's kind of an overall feature set of
the x net system one of the main use
cases that we've been using it for is
for data sharing and this is kind of how
we often think of that industry
workflow that initially images are
managed within an x net system that's
private so data coming from the scanner
or PACs goes into an accident-- system
where your your researchers have access
to it and at some point once they have
are ready to share the data they
actually move it to a secondary system
where they can be more open with sharing
the data there's often a selection
process or a subset of the data is made
available and potentially various kinds
of an automation or recoding of the
images and data are done before moving
into the more public system at the
public side there's often still you know
user authentication that's required
users still have to sign data use terms
and it's not just because it's been
moved to this public system the name is
not necessary just automatically
available to everyone there is still an
approval process so we've implemented
this kind of data sharing for the human
connectome project and have shared data
for quite a while now starting as early
as 2012 we've been sharing data sets out
of the human connectome project
including very large amounts of high
resolution functional and structural
imaging we've now finished collection of
data within the HCP and have made it all
available using the internally the what
we call the inter Divi system for
managing the data as it's being acquired
and as we're doing internal workflows
and then through connect MTB which is
the public facing x net instance through
which we make the data available there's
kind of a detailed view of what that
overall workflow looks like and at this
point we've shared it with lots and lots
of users who are 15 thousand people have
created accounts on on the connect MDB
system that includes many many users not
just in the US but around the world
to date the US as downloaded and used
more data than any other country but
China has been rapidly catching up and
we have been sharing data for quite a
while and the data utilization continues
to be very high
we have spikes around data release times
but even outside of that the data access
has been fairly sustained this view is
just of users downloading the data
through our own web portal they've
downloaded over eight petabytes of data
over the last five years we're starting
to see a little bit of a drop-off in
people accessing data through this
resource and that's partly well I'll
tell you why that is in just a second we
also have been shipping these data and
what we call connect them in a box so if
you're at a site that it's really hard
to download really large data sets it's
not necessarily practical to try to do
it over the web so we have been shipping
hard drives this is a terrible terrible
thing to do I it's been super painful
for us but for many of our users it's
really the only practical way to get the
data we encourage them once they have
the hard drives that they make them
accessible to others at their
institutions so that they are all
separately ordering their own copies but
we've sent out several hundred of these
by now both domestically and
internationally but the main reason I
think that the downloads are starting to
drop off is that we do have the data
accessible on the Amazon Cloud through
the Amazon's public data sets program
and so users can just come to our
website sign our naded use terms and
then get AWS submit their AWS
credentials to get a key that allows
them to access the data on the Amazon
Cloud we've had over a thousand users
who've gotten their AWS credentials to
access the data this way and I think
it's turning out to be a popular way to
to get to the data and it's supported in
part by the fact that all of the connect
pipelines have been made available
through than the Neutrik ec2 instance
that can easily be launched on AWS and
then users easy access to all of those
tools as I mentioned this is done
through the AWS public datasets program
which is something they're offering now
to share at no cost to the data
providers storage of that data obviously
to do computation requires to use
downstream users to pay for the
computational resources on the web on
the cloud so hcp obviously is one of the
high-value data sets that are out there
but there are many others here's just a
few I won't go in any detail on these
because we're starting to run a little
short on time in addition to the
datasets there's a lot of data
repositories that are out there that
have long lists of data available across
a number of domains from cancer imaging
neuroimaging and and others so I'm going
to very briefly just for a minute or two
talk about some of our translational
systems that were set up and there's
really kind of two workflows one is if
for a particular individual patient you
want to run some analytic routine that
is developed in the lab and explore how
useful that is on the clinical side the
other is and this is starting to get to
be very popular extracting very very
large datasets from the clinical packs
largely to feed into deep learning
systems that require very large datasets
to train their algorithms so we've
started set up infrastructure to do
these kinds of workflows so this is a
system we call the tip that allows users
to query out to the packs find a case of
interest run one of our docker
containers
that includes an analytic routine
generates some sort of DICOM files from
that container allows a user to do
quality control before pushing back to
PACs if the processing passes quality
control then it could go back into the
PACs obviously this kind of
communication requires work very closely
with the clinic and with the IT
environment and the clinic to approve
this kind of workflow and the kinds of
images are being pushed back to pax but
it can be a very nice way to quickly
translate research capabilities into the
clinic in a controlled way really the
key is this step three where the quality
control is done because that's what
gives the assurance to the clinicians
that the what's being produced and
pushed back to pax it is suitable for
clinical review we've done this with a
brain tumor protocol that's using
resting state fMRI to identify
functional networks around brain tumors
and to help guide a neurosurgeon to
remove the tumor without interfering
with key functional areas such as
language and motor areas when eventually
as the cases gets processed through our
system it gets pushed the Maps we
generate of those functional areas are
sent to the surgical navigation system
which is shown here and then that's
registered to the images and Co register
stereo tactically with the circuit with
the patient during surgery so the
patient can see precisely in
registration with where they're actually
resecting tumor exactly where the
functional areas are very quickly these
large patient cohorts we've started to
get into pulling these kinds of datasets
that can exceed you know hundreds of
thousands of exams so for example we
have a study going here looking at CT
and stroke
that has hundreds of thousands of CTE
exams we're finding you know some
various logistical challenges with doing
that a primary one is actually
interfering with the packs that you know
the IT services are concerned that if we
try to fall hundreds of thousands of
cases as quickly as we can that that
would interfere with clinical use of the
system
and then once the images are moved into
our system there's a lot of challenges
with i/o throughput deep learning tools
that are in place now depend on GPUs and
many many thousands of cores and those
cores are very very hungry for data and
will very quickly throttle your file
systems so that's something that we're
working on now and finding to be one of
the kind of biggest challenges in
dealing with the kinds of data sets that
are being used in deep learning tasks
maybe I'll cut it here because I think
we only have a few more minutes and and
I know the jack wanted to have a few
minutes for some questions so maybe I
can just cut it off here and I'll have
all these slides available so that the
ones I didn't get to people can just
kind of look at on their own time as
they're interested so Jack I'll hand it
back to you thank you so much Dan that
was a really great overview of what is a
very impressive system and it looks like
it's being applied in in many clever
ways that will be of interest to many of
our attendees today one question I had
for you it looks like somebody was
asking about is where can they find
these great tools can they find these on
your website or how should they look for
them I think you can the x net system is
available at x net org so that's really
easy some of the other tools that I
mentioned you can usually just search on
those in Google and they'll pretty
easily come up but the X headed stuff is
all at X net org fantastic and one other
thing that occurred to me is well you've
really talked about the imaging
informatics increasingly in addition to
the imaging
all kinds of associated data other
things like genetics or full genome
sequencing
maybe proteomics or microbiome related
data for example associated with each
subject whose also undergone human
neuroimaging or medical imaging is X Net
does it have the facility to incorporate
that information or is it linked in some
way how does it handle that it can kind
of be one or the other for kind of
simple metrics that might be extracted
from those kinds of complex datasets
those are easily stored in X hat and can
make querying for datasets easier but
for the actual full datasets it's often
the case that you know a system that's
really tailored to that kind of data
so genomic database is more appropriate
for handling and storing and managing
workflows around that particular data
and then you can do your aggregation in
a number of ways the primary way we do
it is using the API and various Python
libraries so we have a library called PI
X net that allows for easy carrying and
searching and pulling data from X net
and Python routines and there's for many
of the other kinds of databases so maybe
like a redcap for example there are also
Python libraries for that so you can use
Python as your environment for querying
across systems and pulling together and
linking data sets
usually the you're using coded
identifiers for your your research
subjects and their visits so that those
would become the key to linking between
between datasets okay fantastic
well once again thank you so much Dan
Marcus from Washington University for
taking part in our beauty Tube gay bb2k
guide to the fundamentals of data
science webinar series I want to thank
everybody who joined us today
please do use your favorite search
engine and look up for more information
on X Nats and its associated tools thank
you everyone
have a great weekend and we'll see you
next time thank you so much Dan
I think you'd hack and everybody